hey guys I'm a be sharp and welcome to
Abby's kitchen for today's what I need a
youtuber review we're taking a peek at
the australian youtuber bonnie rebecca
known for her predominantly plant-based
recipes bonnie has amassed over three
hundred and seventy thousand subscribers
since the launching in 2014 but last
year she became one of the many vegan
youtubers to go unbe ghen which judging
by the public backlash could not have
been easy for her but i've watched a ton
of her videos and totally became a
subscriber I mean this girl has an
infectious attitude and is super cute
now before we get into today's video I
want to remind you that this video is
for entertainment purposes only and is
not meant to diagnose or prescribe any
way of eating so should always speak to
a registered dietician about your
specific needs now before we get to her
meals
I thought we'd watch a few clips of her
describing her new diet and why she made
the switch there are certain foods that
I'm not really eating right now because
they tend to trigger my digestive issues
which also affect my skin I've mentioned
this heaps of times but just in case you
haven't seen those videos I'm not really
eating legumes beans soy wait those are
kind of the main things that I'm
avoiding and I've also reduced my fiber
intake and kind of up to my protein just
as a disclaimer I am not telling you
that you should cut out those foods at
all very healthy foods just for me
personally right now they're not working
and you know what works for me might not
work for you so this is just like a
rundown on what I'm really enjoying
right now what recipes I'm loving and
what's making me feel good so I'm
already digging a Bonnie style and her
approach to talking about her diet
changes with her followers Bonnie is
fully honest in why she's recently made
these diet changes and her disclaimer
about her diet being tailored to her is
such an important note that I think a
lot of youtubers could really learn from
my diet I don't bring it into my home I
don't buy it
however we're saying that um I
definitely I'm not gonna hold myself
back from eating something it has a
little bit of dairy in it under certain
circumstances like if my brother makes
me something that has you know dairy in
it I'm gonna try it when I'm in Europe
next year if there's something that has
some dairy in it I might try that I
don't want to be held to this like
strict diet right now I just really need
to be in a place where I do not have a
label on my diet I feel like that's
where I need to be right now in terms of
my mental health and my relationship
with food and just getting over this
whole vegan movement and everything that
came along with it because there's so
much that you guys might not realize and
might not understand when it comes to my
last few years because so much happened
behind the scenes I think this is really
a really great point so bonnie mentions
that she doesn't want to feel trapped in
a strict diet she doesn't want to label
her diet or create walls that would
prevent her from eating intuitively and
I think that's a really great approach
it's very much aligned to how I feel
about my diet and my relationship with
food I'm sure that you know making that
public switch to eating eggs and fish
and now chicken wasn't easy but I really
commend her bravery for doing what's
best for her body ok so now that we've
learned a little bit about Bonnie let's
take a closer look at some of her
breakfast from some previous videos
we're gonna do these what a today's a
little bit differently as I mentioned
where I'll be looking at a few meals
from various videos so that there's less
cherry-picking going on and I can get a
more accurate look of her diet and
channel so let's take a look at
breakfast number one so for breakfast I
had two pieces of gluten-free toast with
some avocado and two eggs and then I
also cooked up some mushrooms on the
side I just sauteed them in a little bit
of olive oil some garlic and some Oregon
oh I was really feeling those flavors
this morning and it turned out really
really good also had a cup of tea
standard yeah that was pretty much
breakfast I'll see you guys at lunch
time oh my gosh I love this breakfast
everything about it healthy fats veggies
grains and protein in the eggs
I want it it looks absolutely amazing so
let's take a look at breakfast number
two I do put this on my Instagram story
the other day but if you all gonna try
Vegemite make sure you have it with some
sort of butter I use not alike so I put
like a layer of neither legs down and
then you've got to put a really thin
layer
do you might you do not want to put too
much because if you do it's definitely
gonna ruin it and don't try it like on a
spoon cuz I've had a lot of people say
oh I tried Vegemite like on a spoon and
it was horrible no don't try it like
that you have to have it on toast with
butter on a de legs and it's so much
better when you when you it's like that
yeah so I had that on one piece and then
the other piece I just had some almond
butter with a little drop of honey as
well and then I just put some almond
milk in my cup of tea as well and yeah
it was perfect exactly what I felt like
on a cold morning not very exciting I
know but it's just honestly what I ate
today I agree with Bonnie that Vegemite
is definitely an acquired taste that
personally I have yet to acquire but I
love the approach that bonnie is taking
with her meals I mean some morning she's
craving a larger meal while some
mornings she's just not her meals aren't
set in stone and can even just change
depending on the season or how she's
feeling so that makes sense to me I mean
we all go through changes in our
cravings from sweet or savory or big or
small so I love how Taylor her meals are
whatever she is feeling in that moment
that is ultimately the intuitive eating
philosophy and I think she embodies it
really really well love this meal I love
a good toast breakfast and I like that
she's added that almond butter in there
for some extra satiety with the healthy
fats and the fiber and the and the
protein as well so let's take a look at
breakfast number three a tablespoon of
chia seeds then I never really measured
this but I'm just taking some shredded
coconut and kind of sprinkling that
fruit I'm also trying out adding in some
protein powder to my diet so I just have
some Amazonia protein powder and I'm
going to do one scoop of that and then
I'm going to add some frozen blueberries
and then I'm gonna do some almond milk
and I'm just going to do double of
whatever I put oh why so I'm just gonna
put one cup maybe just under one cup now
that's pretty much it I don't want to
add too many ingredients in this because
I just find it easier to digest when
it's nice and simple I will add a little
bit of peanut butter to it when I serve
it up in the morning gonna pop a lid on
this and pop it in the fridge and yeah
now we're done overnight oats look great
I mean it's simple and easy and I love
the added fat and protein from the
peanut butter and the chia seeds it's a
great meal prep option for people who
are on the go okay so now I'm gonna give
my overall thoughts on breakfast overall
I really like Bonnie's breakfast these
are all things that I would want to eat
maybe not the Vegemite but in general
they're really simple to pull off
they've got variety and they're really
based on what she's craving that day
overall there's a really nice balance of
protein carbohydrates fiber and fat
which really makes the perfect fuel to
start the day okay so now let's take a
look at some of Bonnie's lunches from
some of her previous videos really
simple lunch I've just got some baked
veggies and some lettuce and some
avocado and to spice it up a little bit
I'm gonna make this sauce which I
haven't made in so long the closest
thing I could compare it to is kind of
like a peri-peri sauce and it's really
delicious and I just feel like making it
to have some in the fridge if I want to
put it on anything so let's do that so
just in a little blender thingy
I'm gonna take some roasted capsicum or
peppers whatever you call them this is
hard to undo run it under some hot water
oh goodness
okay so I'm just going to take out one
of these peppers I'm gonna add about two
tablespoons of
shoes heaped tablespoons maybe a little
bit more fun tablespoon of olive oil two
tablespoons of oh yeah two tablespoons
of nutritional yeast I'm totally just
winging this by the way pinch of onion
powder and garlic powder and also a
little bit of paprika what else what
else Oh juice of half a lemon salt and I
think I'll do two tablespoons of water
see how that one's and if it needs more
water I'll add it try this to see if
it's right
[Music]
tastes like peri-peri I feel like it
tastes like Perry Perry have a bit of a
drizzle and I will just put the rest of
this sauce in a container and keep it in
the fridge and use it over the next few
days so I'm kind of mess it up a little
bit now but this is the finished product
I've just got some baked cauliflower
some baked pumpkin some lettuce and some
avocado this sauce is so good with
cauliflower so this meal might seem a
little bit small and to be honest it is
in comparison to my other meals I
usually have a bigger breakfast and a
bigger dinner and a smaller lunch and
ideally I would have some protein with
this but I can't have any plant sources
of protein like legumes or beans or tofu
because of my digestion so yeah I'm kind
of just having like salad and veggies at
lunch time and then having my protein
with my eggs and like speciall something
at night I'm gonna grate this because
this sauce is really yummy and I'll talk
to you guys off to us okay so I agree
with Bonnie that this is a smaller meal
and most people would find that they
would need a little bit more protein to
keep them feeling satisfied longer with
fewer blood sugar dips and things like
that but I get that her unique digestion
situation kind of threw a wrench in
conventional meal planning and she's
coming up with a solution that she feels
good about which is you know having some
bigger meals at the beginning and the
end of the day with more protein and
sling a little bit lighter in the middle
of the day but like I said I mean some
meals will just inherently be smaller
and some will be larger and they don't
always have to look exactly the same
it's it's really the general pad
that ultimately matters hence the shift
in the structure of these videos and the
reviews on my part at least what I'm
seeing is a lot of complex carbohydrates
fiber healthy fats and those
macronutrients are what's going to help
carry her through to the next meal let's
take a look at lunch number two lunch I
had like I guess you could call it like
an Irish ball with some scrambled eggs I
always try to keep like either some
baked pumpkin and usually like a grain
like some millet or some quinoa in my
fridge ready to go because I just think
it's so much easier to make lunch or do
you know when you already had like your
basics kind of prepped so all I really
needed to cook were the eggs so I just
took two eggs and I scrambled them up
and I cooked them in a little bit of
olive oil with some spring onions some
curry powder and some onion powder and I
just cooked that for a few minutes it
doesn't take long oh and I also added a
little bit of salt and pepper
and then I just lay it up the nourish
bowl starting off with some millet and
adding in some pumpkin and also some
cucumber and some rocket and then the
scrambled eggs and then I just topped it
off with some avocado and like this
mustard sauce that I have and I just
popped that on there as well then I
topped off the whole dish with some
roasted tamari
almonds and I just chopped them up and
sprinkled them on top I loved topping my
meals with roasted almonds and
especially tomorrow almonds because
they're so delicious but yeah I just
find that they adds so much flavor and
crunch and just like really make the
meal so much more exciting and when
you're eating an Irish Bowl you got to
make sure you got to mix it up because
you need to make sure you get all those
flavors I do not count calories or
restrict my calories or count macros or
anything like that I have just focused
on reducing the fiber my diet and kind
of making sure that my meals are really
balanced with having lots of healthy
fats and protein in there yeah that
nourish ball looks crazy delicious and
also really well-balanced be you know
she's got the protein from the eggs in
there fibre from all those veggies and
lots of healthy fats from the avocado
and nuts I also love that Bonnie
provides substitutions for people who
don't eat eggs like using the crumbled
tofu and I'm also digging
he's point about not counting calories
or tracking macros her goal is
ultimately to make sure her meals are
nicely balanced and fuel her body well
which is exactly what I'm trying to
promote here on Abbey's kitchen okay
let's look at lunch number three so this
is what we've got going on for lunch I
have put in containers some spinach the
sauce cucumbers sweet potato my quinoa
and brown rice mix some boiled eggs and
this is what it looks like once it's all
been put together I've just added on
some avocado and also some sesame seeds
which I always keep in a container I
just roast them in the pan for a second
and then put them in a container
I love topping them on all of my food
before I continue on with dinner and
breakfast I'm going to eat this
delicious Bowl that I've got right here
oh my gosh that salad looks so yummy
and again really balanced I mean lots of
high-fiber whole grains lots of veggies
healthy fats from the nuts and the
protein and the eggs I mean I love it
I'm also personally obsessed with peanut
satay sauce and I could legit put that
stuff on everything okay folks let me
give you my overall lunch thoughts
overall honestly I am very impressed by
Bonnie's lunch recipes they are packed
with veggies whole grains and lots of
plant-based proteins honestly I wish
that my lunges look like Bonnie so yeah
I'm feeling pretty inspired let's move
on to dinner
I love taco night that looks so fun and
so many great components here we've got
corn and salsa and cheese and tortillas
and guacamole and slaw and beans and
taco shells and fish and a walnut
cauliflower meat filling with lots of
healthy fats and fiber I want it all
also I really appreciate that she isn't
explicitly cutting out any oils or fats
or carbs or really you know anything
major I mean I'm not sure how much she
ate but I love taco night and I also
have a recipe for a walnut cauliflower
filling which I'll leave in the
description below but basically I just
want to be Bonnie's friends so that I
can get invited to her next taco night
the main theme of the sauce and then I
just usually toss the sauce through the
noodles to make sure that like if they
absorb that and they don't get like all
stuck together and then I just top it
off with the patch wait the salmon more
of the sauce and then also some sesame
seeds some roasted sesame seeds so I
just Chuck some sesame seeds in oh my
god I just said sesame seeds so many
times that I just put some sesame seeds
in a pan and like roast them off for a
second and then usually just store them
in a little container for like the week
and that way they're always ready to go
and I find that they just add so much
flavor similar to the almonds like it's
a simple thing to do on top of your your
meals but it really just makes them so
much better and also some spring onions
I'm obsessed with spring onions right
now I pretty much put them on anything
so I will probably sprinkle a little bit
of that on top as well and maybe even
some coriander if I'm feeling it yeah
that's gonna be my dinner I mean this is
I haven't had it yet but that will be my
dinner and you're watching it right now
ah yeah another really amazingly
delicious looking bounce meal I I'm
totally loving Bonnie's sauces and
marinades like this ginger tamari sauce
here I'm totally gonna steal that but
this meal is jam-packed with healthy
fats protein carbs I mean I love the
salmon we know it's got those
heart-healthy omega-3 s we've got the
brown rice noodles in there we've got
the bok choy that's been sauteed this
looks awesome and I also love the idea
of pretty roasting like a whole batch of
sesame seeds so that they're ready to go
and you can just throw them on to any
meal not only do they add like a nice
little crunch and lots of flavor but
they also add those really good healthy
fats as well YUM that pesto looks so
good and I love adding avocado to my
pesto as well especially if you are
trying to make it plant-based it just
adds that creamy consistency but it's
also really a great way to add some
healthy fats but this is a really nice
kind of meal prep dinner to serve with
some fish I know she mentioned that she
would have this with fish you would of
course get the protein and the fish lots
of veggies and carbs from the pumpkin I
mean if anyone wants to take notes on
how to build a balanced Bowl this girl
is legitimately killing it one thing I
would mention if you're not super cool
with having like just zucchini for
dinner as the noodle base so that's what
I like to do is kind of stretch out my
typical pasta by mixing in some zucchini
noodles in there as well so you can kind
of do half in half and if you're unsure
how to make zucchini pasta without it
getting really soggy and droopy and sad
I'm gonna leave a link below to a
foolproof zucchini noodle pasta dish
that requires you to salt the zucchini
to draw out some of the extra moisture
via osmosis I mean yes it's super
sciency but it really does work and that
has been my trick to making the most
amazing zucchini noodle dishes
okay so let's give my final thoughts on
some of Bonnie's dinners overall I love
Bonnie's dinners I mean they're nutrient
dense they're packed with healthy fats
and grains I mean even though pregnant
Abby is not feeling salmon right now to
be honest I would totally consider it
whipping up some for salmon recipes
I also love that she provides
substitutions for certain ingredients
making her recipes really really
flexible and accessible to her followers
let's talk about Bonnie's nutrition
first of all our meals bounced I mean
based on her most recent wedding today's
I would call Bonnie's recipes very
balanced and nutrient-dense bonnie has
mentioned in a few of her videos that
she always kind of make sure her meals
are properly balanced with protein and
healthy fats which is great
based on a very rough calculation I
would estimate that Bonnie's getting
around 1900 to 2000 calories per day and
she's getting a nice balance of healthy
fats protein and carbs in her meals
I mean Bonnie if you ever want to head
to Toronto and make me lunch I am game
now is Bonnie and missing out on any
nutrients so due to digestive issues
Bonnie mentions that she avoids wheat
soy legumes and beans
that being said based on her meals I am
absolutely not concerned with her fiber
or protein intake I mean she's getting
plenty of fiber from fruits and veggies
and grains like quinoa and millet and
rolled oats from her overnight oats
I mean she's also getting plenty of
protein from fish and eggs protein
powder and nut butter even if she's not
eating protein like a source of of
obvious protein like eggs or fish at
every single specific meal it's very
easy for protein to be added up
throughout the day she's also mentioned
that she has low iron levels so she's
taking a supplement for that which is
great self-care now each of her meals
are packed with veggies that are rich in
antioxidants and micronutrients so I am
NOT concerned with her meeting her
micronutrient needs either she seems to
just genuinely crave variety and lets
her body be her guide which i think is
truly amazing now have I seen any
problematic claims or assumptions on her
channel after taking a close look at her
channel in reviewing a lot of her videos
I did find that Bonnie really does seem
to avoid any problematic claims or
assumptions with regards to diet and
really spends more times just sharing
her meal tips and recipes
whenever Bonnie discusses her own
restrictions she is in no way pushing
that style of diet on her followers and
instead disclaim
that this diet works for her and her
digestion alone there was also a video
where she looked back and commented on
her own self and her own misinformed
beliefs or statements which I just think
shows so much growth in a world filled
with so much misinformed online
influencers I'm so happy - a fan of
channel geared towards health-conscious
foodies without the food shaming or
problematic claims so let's talk about
some of my favorite takeaways from
Bonnie's channel number one the
delicious easy and balanced recipes
honestly this girl could write a book on
balanced eating her meals are beautiful
they're unique they're flavorful and
almost always take all of the boxes when
it comes to fiber protein healthy fats
and lots of colorful veg I want to make
them all number two is her intuitive
eating and body positive language based
on some of her recent videos it's
obvious that bonnie has started to take
an intuitive eating approach since
really changing her diet in one video
she talks about how she doesn't count
her water consumption and instead just
listens to her body's needs emphasizing
the importance of hydration without
being punishing about it in another
video I saw when sharing her dietary
restrictions bonnie reminds her audience
that she's not telling them to cut out
those foods and that these foods can
have a really great role in a healthy
diet personally for Bonnie those foods
just aren't working in our diet and what
works for her might not work for you
again bonnie is asking her viewers to
listen to their own body to find what
works for them we need more youtubers
like this please I am also digging
Bonnie's use of body positivity language
in one video
Bonnie discusses unrealistic body
standards online and speaks in pretty
body positive language I mean you don't
see a lot of this being called out
online especially on YouTube so kudos to
you'd by number three the general
disclaimers throughout her video there
are quite a few moments in her videos
where she looks back and comments on her
own self and misinformed beliefs or
statements which as I mentioned I
totally respect and love this type of
reflection
it's really important not only for her
but also for her followers and I've
personally been doing this a lot and I
really want to continue to do more of it
youtubers are allowed to change and
evolve and as we grow and learn and are
exposed to different experiences our
philosophies do change as well so I like
seeing that growth in Bonnie and in her
channel even if it means sometimes
watching really uncomfortable
cringe-worthy content
girl I feel you there bottom line it was
honestly a pleasure to explore at
Bonnie's channels and see some of her
recent what I in the day videos her
meals are simple delicious and
nutritious and I will definitely be
grabbing some of her recipes to cook up
at home it's also refreshing to see
Bonnie's channel evolve and I look
forward to keeping up with her intuitive
eating journey hats off to you Bonnie I
give your channel a solid play now let
me know what are your thoughts on this
new format for my what I ate in the days
I would also love if you would leave me
a comment below with any one that you
want me to review next also subscribe to
the channel like this video and I will
see you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]